WHILE WE WERE OFF THE AIR YOU
GUYS KEPT PLAYING ALONG WITH US
ONLINE.
THANK YOU FOR IGNORING YOUR
FAMILY.
FOR INSTANCE,@AARONROSENFELD
CREATED THIS ONE AFTER OUR OUR
BORING VIDEO GAME.
IT SAYS "HALO, IT ISN'T ME
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR."
TURNING OUR ATTENTION AFFAIR
WITH THAT, IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
I'VE MISSED IT SO MUCH.
GUY INS!
GUYS!
IT IS 2014!
WELCOME TO THE FUTURE!
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR NEW
YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS IS TO READ
MORE BOOKS.
A BOOK IS LIKE A PRINTOUT OF THE
KINDLE YOU DON'T USE.
(LAUGHTER)
SO IN HONOR OF YOUR FAILED
RESOLUTION WE'LL UPDATE CLASSICS
WITH TONIGHT'S #TAG FUTURE
BOOKS.
EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE #A TALE
OF TWO TWIN CITIES, #MOBY DICK
PICS.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
PAUL SCHEER?
>> PRIDE, PREJUDICE AND
TWERKING.
>> Chris: POINTS!
KUMAIL?
>> BLOG OF ANNE FRANK.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
ANDREA?
>> BRAVE NEW WORLD OF WAR CRAFT.
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS!
CUE SNAIL
>> WARTS OF BEING A WALL
FLOWERS.
>> Chris: ANDREA?
>> MAPQUEST SHRUGS.
>> Chris: BRAINY!
FALL?
>> THE GIRL WITH THE DRAGON EMOJ
>> Chris: YES!
>> OH, THAT'S SUCH A SAD TEXT.
>> Chris: ANDREA?
>> A TIME TO KILL-- PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
PLAYING CALL OF DUTY.
>> Chris: POINTS!
PAUL?
>> TYLER PERRY'S "LORD OF THE
RINGS."
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I WAS GOING SAVE THAT FOR CRINGE
WORTHY.
>> Chris: KUMAIL?
>> GRUMPY CAT ON A HOT TIN ROOF.
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS!